kyle mueller has been very impressive
with 20 strikeouts in his first 15 big
legions yeah he sure has you see his
numbers in four games this year three
starts one and two record his last
timeout in the big leagues against miami
took the loss five and two thirds
innings of four four-hit three-run
baseball his last couple of starts down
in triple-a have been were really good
ten innings pitch two are in runs 15
strikeouts so let's look for more of
that game one of two today from atlanta
and fam stepping in hitting at 268
overall in the year
that's something you don't see often
this is not a swing and miss padre team
they put it in play just like that but
jack peterson
is there for round number one
one out it brings up fernando first in
slugging ops and stolen bases gives you
an idea of everything he can do he has
speed he has power
and he sends this one into left field a
base hit for tatis
one out single the wide turn but they
get back to first one out one on for the
padres is he wearing a swag chain he
might be i could just imagine freddie
freeman saying to fernando you know my
son likes you more than me and i'm his
dad
two two pitches lifted softly towards
shallow left
garcia is there good to have orlando
back in the lineup cronenworth is
retired and here's
manny machado shift again to the left
side of the infield pitch on the way to
myers swung on a ground ball out to
third taking on two hops by riley hops
over towards first makes a good throw
and there's out number three
so mueller gets through it no runs one
hit no errors two men left we played a
half an inning we head to the bottom of
the first inning chris panic on the
mound
for the padres 25 year old chris paddock
18 start of the season second against
these braves uh almost five and a half
era 276. let's see if he can locate the
fastball down and away to both sides of
the plate
and then land that curve ball early to
set up possibly a fastball up and out of
the zone for the swing and miss
rolls it up there and a fly ball
to center field pro far is out there and
he makes a catch for out number
swing and one
miss an elevated fastball at 97 by him
first strikeout of the day for padding
up the ladder he wanted it in misses up
cannot get on top of it and swanson is
late two down in the first center comes
freddie freeman two and two paddock into
his delivery and the pitch to freeman is
swung on and grounded to second base
nice backhand by hassan kim his throw to
first in time and a one two three bottom
of the first inning for chris paddock
scoreless in atlanta as we go to the
second
jammed ozzy there and pops it up paddock
rivas and uh tatis and there is out
number one big bear hug with the padres
batteries patek and rivas almost
collided and the
san diego right-hander set down the
first four graves in order 15 homers 45
driven in for austin who was over three
last night got hit in the ribs with a
pitch 2-0 and a fastball sent right back
to paddock deflects off of him goes out
to kim his throw to first is in time and
now we check on chris it might have
gotten glove it might have gotten wrist
for the moment it appears he's okay just
gave a thumbs up two-two pitch
and his whack to left field to base him
it'll be just one bag for herredia it
takes a big turn at first base but it
keeps the inning alive and there's the
first pace of the ball game for the
braves a two out single by herrera made
a mistake with a change-up
pitching coach out there to talk to
mueller after back-to-back walks here
and a nine-pitch plate appearance for
fernando tatis junior before getting the
walk andre's trying to take advantage of
back-to-back walks here in the third
inning with one out and with the heart
of the order here jay cronenworth
swing and a shot hammer toward right
center field peterson reaches up and
makes the play
no advance by the padre base runners
jack peterson got a great jump and
reached up to rob cronenworth of a hit
and maybe more yeah sometimes you got to
be a little lucky as a pitcher too
fastball up and in cronenberg hammered
it jock got a great jump and at the last
minute extends reaches up makes a great
catch here's the o2
hit high and deep to left field going
back is arcia he's at the track at the
wall has room wow makes the catch right
in front of the 385 marking on the left
center field wall
two down and smith at third here's
dansby swanson
and a ground ball diving at second as
kim picks himself up and throws out
dansby swanson nice play by hassan kim
for a third one out of the inning
and kim swings at this one jolts it out
to center field horadia will make the
catch
tagging at third as pro far he will
score the game's first run and the
padres strike first on top one to
nothing
kim who had done it with the glove
earlier it's a sac fly clearly mueller
wants to stay down in the zone trying to
get that ground ball
chris paddock working with the lead for
the first time today freddie freeman
leading it off
elevated and a liner that ken comes up
with
hassan kim has been outstanding in this
game defensively line drive off the bat
of ferdie freeman and hassan kim says no
ends lasting with a diving stop to
retire swanson this inning he starts
standing off with a jumping catch there
that probably ends up being a base hit
one on and a walk and a single for
fernando today he's been aboard twice
high drive to deep left field for
fernando tatis jr gone home run number
29 of the season fernando
padres add on to their lead take a
two-nothing lead well you can't miss
there tatis gets a fastball middle
middle and he cooks this ball to left
field that's fernando banging the drum
right there oh yeah i hear the drums
and i'm sure he does too oh it really
changes the way this game feels so
here's el monte a switch hitter batting
left-handed against his former teammate
breaking ball
a little bloop to shallow center and
diving forward as pro far
jurickson profile with a catch
for out number two i thought that ball
was gonna drop laying out does he do a
face plant on that grass
oh you bet he doesn't oh my gosh stuff
flying everywhere it's the yard sale a
grass sandwich but now base hit could
make it a one-run ball game austin riley
is one for two
as that one got away here comes freddie
he's going to score the first run on a
wild pitch thank you very much nazi
albies over to third base and the braves
on the board as that one got through the
catcher and rolled over there to the on
deck circle on the third base side and
the two to riley he hits a high towering
fly ball to deep center field playable
for profar he's under it alby's tagging
at third the catch is made ozzie will
sprint to the plate he dashes across and
it's now a 3-2 ball game two down in the
seventh the panda pablo sandoval
and it's a ground ball softly it towards
second kim will go glove to glove for
the win
four to three on the put out of sandoval
and the padres hold on and win three to
two over the atlanta braves and the
padres take game one of the doubleheader